it's been a sort of an interesting
journey for me the fact that I ended up
playing King Arthur because John
Boorman's Excalibur was the film that I
became obsessed with as a child about
six or seven that made me want to become
an actor in the first place so cut to 30
years later to be hired by Guy Ritchie
one of my favorite directors to play the
title role felt really significant to me
and then when I saw the trailer and Led
Zeppelin came on and for the first time
in my career my name was above the title
it said Charlie Hunnam boom King Arthur
I said here we go
right and only up from from here on that
[Applause]
and then your brother attacked you from
behind yeah revenge served cold you know
it's interesting the the Guy Ritchie has
this ability to find funny moments even
in scenes where you think as originally
written they weren't maybe meant to be
funny there's a lightness to a Guy
Ritchie that I really admire yes which
was not the intention at all in this
film I think he'd wanted to do something
much more somber and in serious and and
we cut to set and that's not what
happened but I think it was good because
if we'd set out to make it funny we
would have ended up in Monty Python
territory yeah so we set out which is
not a bad thing but no no you want to do
that intentionally yes so yeah this is a
we have a clip here from the film and I
believe this is where your character
before he realizes obviously that he's
King Arthur is not the well he's from
the lower order is that fair to say he's
yeah he grows up in a brothel yeah
completely unaware of his his noble
lineage and then is told that he's King
and says well that's wonderful but I'm
actually quite enjoying my life as it is
so get somebody else to do that right of
course it's not that quite that simple
and he gets coerced into accepting his
destiny we have a clip here I believe
this is where some of the gentlemen are
trying to persuade you and let's see
what happens and you do not want any
part of this let's take a look at this
clip from King Arthur I'm gonna tell you
right now
I'm not getting drawn into this mess
there's an army of you so he wanted me I
haven't had a fight for years and I'll
talk I'm happy to talk but there is no
way that I am fighting
that's cool movies supposed to be right
mighty agro yeah that was the Trinity
bound you gotta play possum when you
throw in a family where you're fighting
with each other yeah this is great
training that's right
you